yo you have always been really good at
expanding like
the West Coast [__] to like other areas
we talk about obviously the cash money
situation you had a great relationship
with Fat Joe back in the day
um what what do you like a tribute to
that because I do feel like you kind of
like a lot of La guys were just kind of
like working with other La guys but you
did a really good job of like breaking
out of that mold and just working with
everybody from all over the place I'm a
player
you know players is internationally
known nationally recognized and locally
accepted you feel me
I'm a player man if you trying to get to
it you you got to step outside your
neighborhood yeah you feel me so so I
[__] with who [__] with me you know
regardless of where they from uh or any
of that if you [__] with me I'll [__]
with you you know so so I always had
that kind of mentality you know so I was
always trying to expand and I you know
it's good to have allies everywhere man
you know what I'm saying I'm I'm
thinking like I've always thought big
yeah was there for anybody you tried to
sign to who banging that was like that
ended up going on to being like really
big that like maybe it almost happened
or didn't you know almost got to the
finish line but maybe for whatever
reason it didn't work out smooth Snoop
yeah was this after yeah he was already
it was when when death row was like you
know when he was before he went to no
limit so before he went to No Limit you
guys had those combos paperwork was done
wow yeah that's crazy so
death Rose obviously a rap snoop's a
free agent
and you approach him to come on who
banging and it almost happens I mean if
he a free agent and I'm in the game you
know what kind of [__] would I
be not to shoot for the biggest free
agent out there that's real [__] you
know Jerry Jones gonna shoot for the
coldest [__] out there if he if
he can get his hands on it yeah you feel
me so how close it was really close to
happening when did the paperwork
literally was done it's just you know
some things you know went on but like it
was it was done it had been crazy yeah
yeah Snoop on who banging records yeah
who's not that'd been crazy too just for
like the perceived politics of that
because like snoop's a big grip you know
we know who you are yeah that'd have
been crazy yeah especially in the 90s
boy listen man I feel like he would have
probably put out some better music too
because I didn't like the first I didn't
like the game is to be sold not to be
sold I didn't like that album I did like
No Limit top dog but yeah shout out to
Snoop that have been crazy